and traditionally about medical research
then you do an experiment it tries to
reduce the opportunity in the data to
make sure that when the conclusions are
made there is no known confounding
factor instead what we have been
focusing on is using a lot of data
that's very heterogeneous from my
colleague dirty data and use this a
large amount of dirty data to identify a
signal for an image that is look buzz
across multiple independently data and
it's clinically useful and it showed
that this approach works in broad
numerators and broad number of abilities
including community this organ
transplant accessibility cancers for
identifying diagnosing improvements from
markers in target and so we applied our
our dirty data approach to identify a
diagnostic signature for tuberculosis
wonder of the world is infected with the
latent tuberculosis and about 180
hundred ninety million people worldwide
have actively being but even in science
essentially we it's very difficult I am
to be and what were able to show is that
using 20600 blood samples from 11
different countries in fourteen
independent cohorts we found that a
three gene signature that distinguishes
who had active TV from who has latent TB
who has other diseases that looked like
TV and were completely healthy with a
very high accuracy and now what we are
working on showing is that it also
allows us to predict who's going to have
actively be much much earlier than
clinical diagnosis it correlates with
treatment response and that it can be
used as a screening tool for identifying
the patients who may have active TB
engine which will take